welcome back to cbs this morning new
york city was once the epicenter of the
coronavirus outbreak here in the u.s
but this morning after nearly three
months of being shut down the city is
beginning phase one
of its reopening and as states reopen
across the country
17 have reported an increase in average
daily new cases compared with two weeks
ago
and that is raising concerns among some
health experts that there could be
trouble ahead our lead national
correspondent david begno is in new york
city
david good morning so here we go what
does phase one look like
well tony construction projects can
restart manufacturers can fire up their
floors again
and non-essential retailers like
stouffer and boots can reopen it's a mom
and pop shop they are a kid's clothing
boutique
they'll deliver you can't go inside and
browse but you can come right here
curbside pickup
and they'll put what you need right
outside the door listen there were a lot
of businesses in this area of the upper
west side of manhattan that had to close
down because of the shutdown they just
couldn't afford the rent
so you can't imagine how happy this
woman who owns this place is
to have that door open behind me
it's so personal when it's a small store
and i really feel connected
to my customers and i just feel like i
haven't seen them in so long
that's stephanie goldstein she owns
stoofer in boots
she says while they were closed her
online business really took off
how much do you pay and rent a month for
the store oh
you'll cry it's close to twenty four
thousand dollars has this made you think
about
maybe i should do this online because
i've done pretty well online
no i love having my store officials
estimate
400 000 new yorkers will return to work
today
80 days after the city went on lockdown
bill de blasio
is the mayor every new yorker should
celebrate
as our achievement together your
achievement because you did the hard
work
to fight back the coronavirus to date
more than two hundred thousand residents
have tested positive for the virus
the death toll is estimated to be just
over twenty one thousand
now the next phase of reopening could be
just weeks away
[Applause]
but after months of hard-won progress
against the coronavirus
there are concerns that the massive
demonstrations in the wake of george
floyd's death
could have given the virus a chance to
spread again just listen
to the governor andrew cuomo we've
tested everything else we've measured
everything else everything was going
fine
then we had these large number of
protests we don't know what the effect
of those protests are
and we're concerned about it
and that concern isn't specific to new
york city
this was washington d.c on sunday tens
of thousands of people have marched
there over the last 10 days
about a week before those protests
started dr deborah burks of the white
house coronavirus task force
said this the number one metro with the
highest positivity rate
is the district of columbia dr burks
also called attention to the rates of
positive cases in chicago
where tens of thousands of people
protested there over the weekend
and she warned that cases were still
rising in minneapolis
since george floyd was killed there on
may 25th that city has been the site of
some of the largest
memorials and demonstrations around the
country well look we're certainly going
to see transmission coming out of these
gatherings there's no question about
that
that is the former fda commissioner
scott gottlieb
he told face the nation moderator
margaret brennan that people who
attended protests in
any u.s city should maintain social
distancing and take
extra precautions like avoiding the
elderly these are occurring in hot spots
we're likely to see cases go up i think
trying to tease out
what the contribution is from the
protest versus the contribution just of
the general reopening is going to be
hard
here in new york city there are 15
testing sites set up just to test people
who went to the demonstrations
the governor of new york is hoping
they're able to test 35 000 people every
day
now that the city is starting to reopen
and gail i cannot tell you how exciting
it was to come from my apartment
to this store and look down the blocks
and see doors open lights on and people
inside i feel you david i feel you
listen but i think people need to
remember
just because we're reopening doesn't
mean it's over so you have to be careful
that said i don't know what a stooper is
but i sure like to look at that store
stuffer and boots
very nice makes you want to do something
over there thank you david thank you